كل ما أعود إليه هو الأخبار العاجلة هذه
الساعة، تنفذ إسرائيل
ضربات عسكرية ضد حماس في غزة بعد أن
شنت الجماعة هجومًا مفاجئًا في وقت مبكر من يوم
السبت، ويزعم مقاتلو حماس أنهم
أطلقوا حوالي 5000 صاروخ استهدفت
المطارات والمواقع العسكرية،
ويقول المسؤولون الإسرائيليون إن صاروخًا واحدًا على الأقل
قُتل شخص وأصيب ما لا يقل عن 100 شخص،
ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي أيضًا إنه
سيحشد الآلاف من جنود الاحتياط
لمواجهة حماس. انضم إلي الآن، دانييل
ليفي، رئيس مشروع الشرق الأمريكي،
شكرًا جزيلاً لوجودك هنا معنا، لذلك
أريد فقط أن  ابدأ برد
فعلك على الأحداث غير المسبوقة التي
نشهدها
الآن حسنا أعتقد أن أول شيء نلاحظه
كيم طبعا هو عنصر المفاجأة هذا والنجاح
المذهل حقا في هذا الصدد أه من قبل
الحركات الفلسطينية التي
انطلقت  أه هذا الجهد العسكري أعتقد
أنه مع مرور الوقت سيكون له تأثير سيء للغاية في
إسرائيل، أعتقد أنه كان هناك شعور
بأنه يمكنك إبقاء الفلسطينيين في
هذه الظروف وعدم القيام بهذا
النوع من أعمال المقاومة، وأعتقد أن
الشيء المباشر هو أن
اليهود الإسرائيليين  مجتمع الأحزاب السياسية
أه يأتي الممثلين يتحدون
ولكن أعتقد في النهاية أن هذا سيلعب
في استقطاب عميق بالفعل داخل
إسرائيل وأعتقد أن هذا مهما حدث
بعد ذلك سيعتبر
نجاحًا كبيرًا لتلك الحركات الفلسطينية،
ليس من الواضح ما سيحدث بعد ذلك
سيكون مفاجئًا  إذا
لم يتضمن الرد الإسرائيلي في غزة أيضًا أه
عملية برية أعتقد أنكم تعلمون أن هذا
يأتي في وقت لدينا فيه
الحكومة الأكثر تطرفًا في إسرائيل استفزازات لا نهاية لها،
لديكم أيضًا ما يبدو
وكأنه بيئة إسرائيلية داخلية هشة وضعيفة جدًا
وأنا  أعتقد أن
الجانب الفلسطيني قد نظر إلى
تلك الحركات الفلسطينية التي
أطلقت هذا، لقد نظروا إلى
الوضع في القدس، القدس، والذي
لا يتردد صداه لدى الفلسطينيين فحسب، بل
أبعد من ذلك بكثير، لقد نظروا إلى قضايا مثل
كيفية معاملة السجناء الفلسطينيين أه
لقد نظروا إلى
محادثات التطبيع وكان هذا هو
الرد وأعتقد أنه أيضًا
تذكير مهم كما
يدرك مشاهدوك هذا الصباح أن
المشكلة في الشرق الأوسط حقًا ليست ما
إذا كانت إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية من
لسنا في حرب مع بعضنا البعض، تطبيع أم
لا، القضية هي ما يحدث على
الجبهة الفلسطينية منذ عقود طويلة من
الاحتلال لن يكون هناك هدوء أمني
واستقرار طالما أن
الفلسطينيين لا يحصلون على حقوقهم
وحرياتهم وقد قمنا بذلك.  تم تذكير
هذا أيضًا بأنه يأتي في
الذكرى الخمسين لآخر مرة
تعرضت فيها المخابرات الإسرائيلية لفشل فادح وهو
أه حرب 1973 مع مصر
حرب يوم كيبور ولذا أعتقد أن ذلك
سيؤثر على النفس الإسرائيلية وفي
التحليل  'نرى خروجا من
إسرائيل أه هذا الصباح وفي الأيام القادمة